ich kenne kein besseren Nudelsalat als
diesen hier ihr werdet euch direkt eine
ganze Schüssel davon machen wollen das
ist Bella Italia mhm zu allererst mal
kochen wir die Nudeln verfalle Penne
irgendwas was man gut Löffeln kann jetzt
rösten wir ein paar Pinienkerne an und
schnippeln Frühlingszwiebel getrocknete
Tomaten und frische Tomaten die
penenkärne haben schön Farbe bekommen
gebe ich dazu und als nächstes unseren
Mozzarella den zupfe ich ein bisschen
sieht einfach immer schöner aus als wenn
man schneidet also Mozzarella schneiden
ist eigentlich verboten ganz wichtig
nicht an Mozzarella sparen jetzt zum
Dressing wir machen eine vinegre aus dem
Öl das wir von den getrockneten Tomaten
noch haben dazu ein bisschen Senf und
Agavendicksaft dazu noch ein bisschen
Salz block. Shop ihr wisst bescheid und
Pfeffer außerdem balsamikoessig so
verquüle ich das ganze noch bisschen
Zitrone
dazu jetzt folgen unsere mittlerweile
erkalteten Nudeln eine Hand voll Rucola
und unser Dressing jetzt mischen wir das
Ganze durch das ist die Hochzeit alles
verbindet sich saftig knaftig köstlich
schmöchtlich